I care about you like so.
It's ok.
Oh fuck.
You need a hand
with any of this?
-No, I'm good.
-Alright.
I'm Theo by the way.
What's your name?
I'm married
and have these groceries.
They're for my baby.
You.
What are you doing here?
I own the place.
So, you got a new town,
new baby,
new bakery,
banging body.
You're just doing it all.
Stop that.
Stop what?
Flirting.
Ok, so my house is swarming
with reporters
so I did jump my fence
to go get some lunch.
Which is also the story
of why I forgot my wallet.
And now I'm gonna die
starving in destitute.
My issue is that
you're still flirting
and I asked you not to.
I'm not flirting with you,
I'm begging you for food.
If you need some cheap to
free labour at the bakery,
I'm your guy.
Yeah, come
whenever you want.
Hey, stop.
What the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing!
I thought it would
get your attention.
What the fuck!
Come on, this shit's
romantic as fuck.
What are you talking about?
Well, according to all the
romcoms of your generation
this is what the guys
are supposed to do
to get the girl.
I'm sorry.
That's my bad.
You know,
it's not the most subtle
come here of my life,
but I'm really, I'm not
complaining about it.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
Does terrible family tragedy
make people more fuckable?
'Cause could really use
a silver lining.
-Don't do that.
-Yeah.
The fuck.
What are you doing here?
You called me.
You drunk dialled me
at like 4am.
I was worried, so I Uberd.
I can't stop
thinking about you.
While I'm being honest.
It's really hard to stand
here and have a conversation
with you as though I'm not
like totally distracted
by how much I want you.
If you want me to shut up,
I will.
I'm not trying
to be an asshole.
I'm just trying
to figure out...
how I can focus
when all I want is you.
You shut up.
No.
Are you sure?
Run away with me, Love?
I care about you like so.
I love you.
I can't stand it.
I need you to leave.
I need you to leave
Madre Linda
-and never come back.
-Come with me then.
I can't.
Goodbye, Love.
Theo, wait...